The phrase "life imitates art" is one that gets
thrown around often in the United States. However,
in places like North and South Korea, this
saying is often a frightening reality ... and
it doesn't get any less frightening when
you take into account the fact that the
South Korean art that has been making
waves lately has been very, very grim.
Take "Squid Game," for example. When you take
away all the violence and the bright colors,
Netflix's popular survival drama is essentially
a grim social commentary about the bottom ladder
of the social rung, and the way they have to
suffer at the hands of people who have more
power than they do. According to a disturbing
November 23rd news report from Radio Free Asia,
another version of this chilling
story recently became reality
when a man was sentenced to
death because of "Squid Game."
Sometime recently, a high school student from
North Korea was caught buying a copy of "Squid
Game" that had been "smuggled," as RFA describes
it, into the Hermit Kingdom on a USB flash drive.
The student then proceeded
to watch the show, quote,
"with one of his best friends in class,"
according to RFA sources. The sources said,
"The friend told several other students, who
became interested, and they shared the flash
drive with them. They were caught by the censors
in 109 Sangmu, who had received a tipoff."
This reportedly led to the students' arrests,
as well as the capture of "the smuggler" who
originally sold Netflix's survival game series
to them. What happened next might as well have
been an episode of the show at its bleakest.
The person who sold the copy of "Squid Game"
was sentenced to death by firing squad,
after authorities discovered that he brought
the Netflix series into the country from China.
The students also received harsh
punishments, ranging from years of
hard labor to life imprisonment. Reportedly,
the school's principal and two faculty members
were also removed from their positions for
allowing this to happen. RFA's source said,
"It is certain that they will
be sent to toil in coal mines
or exiled to rural parts of the country,
so other school teachers are all worrying
that it could happen to them too if one of their
students is also caught up in the investigation."
All this was done in accordance with the
new "Elimination of Reactionary Thought
and Culture" law, which carries a maximum
penalty of death for anyone caught, quote,
"watching, keeping, or distributing
media from capitalist countries,
particularly from South Korea and the US,"
RFA reports. Sources indicate that the show's
"dystopian world" in which people compete for a
giant cash prize and face elimination by death
resonates with North Koreans who have "risky
occupations and insecure positions." Meanwhile,
North Korea has cast similar blame on its southern
neighbor, with one report from a propaganda site
in October 2021 describing "Squid Game" as a
"brutal" reflection of South Korean society.
According to NBC, many South
Koreans actually do feel like
"Squid Game" accurately portrays the
wealth inequality they experience,
just not on the level that North Korea
says. Security analyst Jung Dunn explained,
"It dealt with such familiar stories of
debt-ridden people you come across in real
life. The story stems from a deeply rooted
perception of how society looks at failure,
especially individual financial failure."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.